-President Trump has canceled
his summit with North Korea.
Meanwhile, he and his allies
are pushing
a baseless conspiracy theory
about the Russia probe.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
President Trump has spent weeks
hyping his upcoming summit
with North Korea.
He's earned glowing praise
from the media,
chants of Nobel from his crowds,
and his government even made
a commemorative coin
to mark the occasion.
And you know what?
I was so excited,
I actually logged on
to the White House gift shop
and bought
one of those coins myself.
Here it is.
[ Cheers and applause ]
There it is.
Because I wanted
to be a part of history.
So here's to you, Mr. President,
and all your success.
-Breaking news.
-Back with our breaking news --
President Trump has just written
a letter to Kim Jong-un,
the Leader of North Korea,
canceling the June 12th
expected summit in Singapore.
-Damn it!
[ Laughter ]
Although, it's my fault.
I should've learned my lesson
after I bought
commemorative coins
for the completed border wall,
"Biggest Inauguration Ever,"
Anthony Scaramucci's
first 100 days on the job,
"Cleared of All Charges,"
and "People's
Sexiest Man Alive."
[ Laughter and applause ]
So, Trump canceled the summit,
which shouldn't surprise anyone.
He earned backslaps
from the media,
desperate to praise him
for something,
but he repeatedly made clear he
had no idea what he was doing.
For example, when he spoke today
at the White House,
Trump urged North Korea
to give up its nuclear weapons.
-North Korea has the opportunity
to end decades
of poverty and oppression
by following the path
of denuclearization.
-There you go.
He wants them to follow the path
of denuclearization.
But when he was asked on Tuesday
how denuclearization worked,
Trump claimed he totally knew
but wouldn't go into detail.
-I do. I have a very strong idea
how it takes place,
and it must take place.
That's what we're talking about.
It must take place.
But I have a very strong idea,
and I have very strong opinions
on the subject.
-Once again,
Donald Trump is a teenager
who didn't prepare
his oral report
and is now stalling
for the bell to ring.
"I know a lot
about the Louisiana Purchase.
It's fascinating --
a fascinating purchase.
And, uh, I have very
strong feelings about it
that I want to show --
Will you ring,
you damn son of a bitch?"
[ Laughter ]
So Trump is flailing
on foreign policy.
Maybe, just maybe,
he's distracted
by the Russian investigation,
which seems to get worse
for him every day.
Since the investigation began,
Trump and his allies
have tossed out one crazy
conspiracy theory after another,
like when Trump said his wires
had been tapped at Trump Tower
or when they said two FBI agents
had a secret society
to undermine Trump.
Trump loves conspiracy theories
so much,
I'm shocked
he hasn't accused Don Jr.
of being a secret lizard person.
[ Laughter ]
"Have you seen
the way he blinks?"
[ Laughter ]
Now, every one of those claims
turned out to be total B.S.
In fact, Trump's crimes
are apparently so obvious
that his lawyer, Rudy Giuliani,
is now trying out a new tactic.
Instead of denying
that collusion happened,
he's saying if it did happen,
it wasn't illegal.
In an interview with
Huffington Post Wednesday...
Yeah, if somebody gives you
something that's stole,
that doesn't
make you a criminal.
It makes you a pawn shop.
[ Laughter ]
Also, are we sure Giuliani isn't
working for Robert Mueller?
First, he told Sean Hannity
that Trump did pay off
Stormy Daniels.
Now this.
If you called Rudy in
for questioning,
you wouldn't
need to do good cop/bad cop,
because he would confess
to the good cop.
[ Laughter ]
"So, can I get you
a cup of coffee?"
"All right, I did it --
I killed my wife!"
"We brought you in
for a robbery."
"I did that, too!"
[ Laughter ]
If Rudy sang Bob Marley
at karaoke,
he'd change the lyrics to,
"I shot the sheriff,
but I did not shoot the deputy.
But even if I did
shoot the deputy,
that wouldn't be illegal.
And, also,
I did shoot the deputy."
[ Laughter and applause ]
So...
[ Cheers and applause ]
So, because
they don't have a good defense,
Trump and his allies
have instead decided
to go on offense, creating
one fiction after another
to discredit
the investigation.
A central figure in that effort
has been Republican Congressman
Devin Nunes,
who in every single photo
looks like he just realized he
brought you the wrong entrees.
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Oh, no.
Oh.
Oh, you said veal?
I thought you said eel."
[ Laughter ]
Nunes has used his perch on
the House Oversight Committee
to extract information
about the investigation
and then use that information
to help Trump
manufacture conspiracy theories.
And it's not just Nunes.
Trump's allies
in the right-wing media
have been happy to run with
his wild spying claims.
Just take Fox News host
Maria Bartiromo.
She accused both President Obama
and Hillary Clinton
of being in a sinister plot
to take down Donald Trump
during the campaign.
Listen as she rambles
through a list
of all the favorite
right-wing buzzwords.
-In March of 2016,
Sally Yates and Loretta Lynch
were both briefed by Jim Comey.
A couple of months later,
we start seeing
all the dossier information
and that there's
a dossier being written.
And then, we know that
that dossier was used
to get a warrant to wiretap
and to spy
on the Trump campaign.
We also know,
based on the text messages
between FBI agent Peter Strzok
and his girlfriend, Lisa Page,
that he said,
"President Obama wants to know
everything we're doing on this."
So...
-Right.
-Where was Obama?
I don't know.
What do those texts
and all of this information
tell us where Obama was?
It sounds like
either President Obama
or Hillary Clinton were sort of
masterminding all of this.
-Think about how insane
that theory is.
She's saying Barack Obama
and Hillary Clinton
sent a spy
to infiltrate Trump's campaign
so they could get dirt on him
and then chose not to use that
dirt during the election.
"Mr. President,
we found the pee tape.
Should we leak it?"
"No, no,
save it for my Netflix deal."
[ Laughter and applause ]
"I got an idea
for a limited series."
[ Laughter and applause ]
You'd watch!
[ Laughter ]
Trump and his allies
are literally
just making [bleep] up,
and because he's the president,
the media thinks
they have to take it seriously.
For example, Giuliani
made headlines over the weekend
when he claimed, out of nowhere,
that Mueller "hopes to finish
the obstruction investigation
by September 1st.
By putting end date
on the obstruction inquiry,
he is apparently seeking
to publicly pressure Mueller
to stick to that timeline.
I'm sorry. You think you
can pressure Robert Mueller?
[ Laughter ]
Look at that dude.
That dude plays Jenga to relax.
[ Laughter ]
He has more steel in him
than Wolverine.
His last job was support beam.
They make skyscrapers
out of Robert Muellers.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Well, this will shock you.
It turned out Rudy's claim about
the September 1st deadline
was entirely made up.
Like Trump,
Rudy just goes on TV,
makes stuff up,
and the media repeats it
because they think they have to.
For example,
Rudy also claimed recently
that the President could just
ignore a subpoena from Mueller
because past presidents
have done the same thing.
But after he said that,
a clip of Giuliani from 1998
resurfaced, insisting that
then-President Clinton
would have to testify
if he was subpoenaed.
-If the president
is asked to testify,
subpoenaed to testify
before a grand jury,
and says, "No,
not gonna do it..."
-You gotta do it.
I mean, you don't have a choice.
-Well, he said in a statement
that he might not do it.
-Well, then, there is
a procedure for handling that.
You go before a judge,
and a judge decides
whether or not
he has a recognizable exemption
or privilege from testifying.
And if a judge
decides he doesn't,
then you have to testify.
You don't have
a choice about that.
-Wow, that interview
has not aged well.
[ Laughter ]
Unlike Rudy Giuliani who doesn't
look a day over Crypt-Keeper.
[ Laughter and applause ]
So, Rudy is obviously lying
and contradicting himself.
And yet the media
keeps talking to him.
Last week on CNN,
Rudy insisted
that if Mueller
were to subpoena Trump,
he would interfere
in the investigation
by going to Attorney General
Jeff Sessions
and Deputy Attorney General
Rod Rosenstein
and telling them
to stop the subpoena.
-If Mueller did it,
the Justice Department
could take the subpoena
right back.
-Or you could just litigate it.
He could subpoena him,
and you could litigate it.
-I'd go right
to the Attorney General,
I'd say, "Jeff, you know,
put on big-boy pants,
and you go take it away.
-But he's recused from this.
-Then I'd go to Rosenstein
and say,
"You want to try
the big-boy pants on for size?
You put them on, and you
get rid of the subpoena."
-Rudy sounds like
a flustered salesman
at a store
called Big Boy Pants.
[ Laughter ]
"What about you?
Two-for-one Big Boy Pants?
Oh, come on, Rudy.
You gotta make a sale!
[ Laughter ]
And I'm sorry,
but if Jeff Sessions
tried to put on big-boy pants,
they'd go up to his nipples.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Now, there is no reason --
no reason to ever believe
what Trump, Rudy or their allies
say about
the Russia investigation.
They've proven
time and time again
they have no compulsion
about lying
and contradicting themselves.
The media should
stop taking them seriously.
In other words,
the media should put on their...
-Big-boy pants.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]